une production du studio sf
bio santé le podcast on parle ce qu on
veut que nos invités dallas est super h
quand tu es avec moi dôme plantes si
vous écoutez en ce moment soit en audio
et vidéo vous ne voyez une entendez dans
le studio sf qui est notre studio et que
vous pouvez louer pour vos projets de
podcasts ou de blogs ou de n'importe
quoi dans le fonds audiovisuel
vous venez si vous avez votre contenu
vous ne faites que vous que pensez à son
équipe de tout le reste on a les
techniciens on a le matériel on ne
laisse pas son nom tout ce qu'il vous
faut vous recevez le matériel deux jours
ouvrables après votre enregistrement
donc aucune raison d'attendre avant de
lancer votre projet studio et servent
point ca pour plus d'informations
cette semaine on discute d'un événement
à fait tragique nouvelle tragique on
entendu dans le temps des fêtes qui le
décès de jean marc vallée en signer à
ton artiste québécois que je pense que
les gens ont peut-être content qu'on
apprécie beaucoup même condamné lire
j'ai décidé en nullité d'inviter un
cinéaste québécois puis quelqu'un qui un
grand grand cinéphile qui est aussi mon
frère pascal accessoirement a tué mon
frère pour parler de leurs de jean marc
vallée a manqué les deux touchés comment
qu'on l'a apprécié enfin une espèce de
rétrospective de ses oeuvres c'est
vraiment par des conversations qu'on a
mis pratiquement film par film en fait
quand on en discute et c'était vraiment
super agréable puis vraiment un grand
plaisir pour moi d'avoir mon frère ce
père castor aujourd'hui cinéma avec lui
c'était un grand grand plaisir j'espère
que vous allez aimer la compensation qui
j'espère que ça vous fait vous donner
envie d'aller visiter ou revisiter les
oeuvres de jean marc vallée ça fait
vraiment c'est une célébration en fait
de son oeuvre plus que une tristesse
face à son destin donc sans plus
attendre avait remercié aux
commanditaires et bonbons écouter le
podcast d'aujourd'hui est présenté par
terje
sont une firme comptable qui font de
comptabilité annunzio il dit on la
quantité de plusieurs plusieurs pme et
facilite la tâche énormément vraiment
une chanson le si on le sait de mehrtens
encore été une année difficile sur le
plan fiscal pour pau plein temps son
point de vue financier 2022 c'est le
temps de bien s'entourer temps d'avoir
une bonne équipe c'est pour ce qui
ternit son le savez plus 30 ans contre
tous au service des pme dans toutes
sortes de domaines alors sont vraiment
vos partenaires financiers vont vous
aider à redresser vous financent donc
fait leur un petit coup de fil tout à
fait pillon aussi maintenant un podcast
qui s'appelle les économies sur lequel
moi je suis allé pour raconter mon
parcours entreprenariale donc si ça vous
intéresse on veut mettre le lien vers
leur balade au dans la description du
podcast du cipi honnêtement une des
affaires que je discute durant ce
podcast le sait à quel point en
entrepreneuriat la chose la plus
difficile du moins à mon point de vue
c'est la discipline fiscale puis si vous
voulez en apprendre plus sur toutes ces
aspects là de la fiscalité et des
finances en fait dans votre entreprise
mais à l'écouter leur balade opi vous
n'allez pas le regretter et sinon je
donne un coup de fil si vous avez une
pme puis 70 d'abord en fait on
département comptabilité quasiment 2
août si c'est vrai c'est de la
répartition comptable qui deviennent
notre département de comptabilité ça
facilite énormément la tâche merci
beaucoup de terrain dans
le podcast de cette semaine et présenté
par auch lagache la keynote fournisseur
officiel de tout produit en alcool ici
au studio sfr s'ils voulaient les
studios badauds et
beuvry un frigo prendre un produit h la
fillette à farid a franchement à gauche
lag ils viennent de lancer vous le savez
sont forts dans l'innovation dans la
nouveauté l'ancienne ville de gan nano
donc si une gamme faible en alcool pour
respecter votre nouvelle votre
résolution en fait du temps des
paillettes et du nouvel an les bières
nano sont parfaites - je bois de la
blonde envie la nano blonde est
excellente faible en alcool sinon tout
est un gars de blanc tout un vote blanc
charlotte blanchet vraiment la blanche
comme sidi
historiques ont le goût de prendre un
petit verre mais pas de sang sur trulli
l'effet de l'alcool la nano choqué ce
roman un parfait compromis aussi la nano
ipod iphone d'alpi étoilée sur auch
like.com pas les regarder la carte
interactive pour voir si collet points
de vente je lie en fait où vous pouvez
vous procurer ces excellents produits il
y en a plein il y en a pour tout le
monde alors
s
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est parti on y est
d'amener mon coeur bonne année ouais
bonne année quand on s'est vu trop
longtemps ses vues à noël on est dans le
même but long pour enlever le plexi
familiale on
voulait de recevoir parce que récemment
il ya une icône du cinéma québécois qui
passe la main qui est
jean marc gales et psychique et il ya ce
que moi j'ai pour toi aussi c'était
quand même un artiste dont les oeuvres
mettons nous ont marqués magique est
aussi non seulement fait que je suis on
a eu un goût d'en parler je pense que
comme
le plus grand cinéphile que je connaisse
à 2007 mon frère fait que ces coiffes et
je leur fais juste le plus grand
cinéphile point ça donne et on fait les
gars qui est que de les plus infimes chi
chi le meilleur pour en parler c'est mon
frère qui ont voté pour moi non mais ça
fait vraiment plaisir et puis c'est le
fun parce que la balade dernière c'est
la deuxième fois que vous recevez merci
des jeux mais la première fois c'est un
peu plus on parlait plus de moi pis moi
j'aime ça parler des erreurs des autres
et j'aime ça aussi moi je tends partager
la musique qui me fait triper les films
qui me font triper été je te donne
premier à comprendre le monde par la
gorge me diras regarde ses blessés
malades puis bon je sais que le contexte
est un peu plus un peu moins festif le
comment effectivement on y est on se lie
dont la mauvaise nouvelle de la fin
d'année ces mauvaises nouvelles de fin
d'année
mais je pense surtout
c'est dans l'optique de célébrer son
oeuf
célébration plus que parce que notre
défi jean marc darriné parce que je suis
mentionne ce parce que jean marc gallet
aussi été difficile en entrevue il n'y
avait pas beaucoup ça parler de lui mais
dès que tu le starter soit quelque chose
qu'il fait c'est passionné puis je pense
que c'est contagieux danser son oeuvre
le lait les chansons qu'il passionne
pitt il y aurait en quelque chose de
très qui irradie puis c'est très
inspirant et jean marc vallée ses mots
ses seuls souvenirs que j'ai pu je peux
peut-être commencer par quelque chose de
plus personnel
la demande est en fait un premier
contact déjà un premier cas un dernier
contact avec avec jean marc vallée pour
moi déjà moi tous les cinéastes qui sont
venus à l'école le quand j'étais au
cégep à l'université moi j'ai fait
l'école de cinéma concorde yeux il leur
dit et je m'en rappelle ça m'a marqué
c'est parce que les professeurs
rapidement ils deviennent rébarbatif
puis bon tu peux c'est l'épreuve de
cinéma mais mon mot du concret qui se
fait le film exemple soit bon j'avais
micheline lanctôt comme professeur aussi
fait que ça allait mais j'avais j'avais
un premier des ratures qui faisait tout
à la blague comme ils commençaient les
sessions à 10 ans l'épreuve de
littérature se décrivent eux n'ont pas
réussi en six ans
c'est plus complexe que ça je le sais
mais quand même ça ça ça donne une vraie
bouffée d'air à l'étudiant le passionné
quitté il ya tout le temps des proches
un petit peu plus et gris parfois qu'ils
vont dire bon il ya x nombre de gens qui
réussiront pas dans le monde du cinéma
statistiquement parlant politique en
somme c'est l'endroit où tu veux juste
pelleter des nuages qui est inspiré à
l'école qui toutes les cinéastes qui
venait bassiste et susciter cette
bouffée d'air lors que l'étudiant cinéma
les étoiles dans les yeux qui nous donne
il y avait eu robert morin que j'adore
qui était venu puis lui a fait un bond
franc parler mais jean marc vallée avait
fait déjà c'était dans l'amphithéâtre à
concordia il y avait des jeux mondiaux
là on est en 2009 2010 barrot a été
quand of défi quant au fait qu hésiter
déjà dessinés
les fleurs sont sur toi puis je pense
qu'il revenait aussi de queen young
victoria donc et aussi le ceci très
québécois peut-être mais
avec des amériques
millions et plus incroyables et et puis
c'est avait été tellement généreux comme
comme rencontre il y avait montré il y
avait eu l'humilité de montrer un court
métrage qui avait fait en début de
carrière avec un jeune marc andré
grondin
les fleurs magiques il y avait je pense
11 ans marc-andré grondin fume que fait
en 95 et dix ans encore izik en main
puis rien montré si il décortique et il
se prenait pas la tête c'est un peu plus
cher aîné de montres et aider certaines
faiblesses de son fait mais il y avait
vraiment une calandre à y avait quelque
chose de très très très inspirant cette
rencontre le avec avec ces grands hommes
et puis ça je m'en rappellerai
définitivement marqué il est filmé ont
marqué ce et sur le défaut que j'ai vu
c'était aux 33 tours qui achetaient des
vinyles ouais donc fidelity price quand
même ce qu'il va
devenir quand même
quand même impressionnant ce qui a je
sais pas ça juste d'en gérer coûte
évidemment il ya crazy de café de flore
digestive mettons les
discothèques des ses personnages sont
quand même déjà pas payer vos images et
la scène doit être quand même encore
plus là on se l'imaginent puiser une
mythologie musicale dans l'oeuvre de
jean marc vallée et études sens un peu
comme
je veux juste faire un mini potes je me
comparez pas j'en encore les le tout le
monde l'émission de du podcast
clairement mais mais moi je fais très
satisfait très mélomane ou si le maton
si parallèle on puisse faire mais je
fais vraiment attention g7 autant que
les personnages de mes films écoute la
musique qui devrait écouter expressément
juste mes choix à monter je sais
vraiment des fois de m'effacer puis de
me dire ok si j'étais jeune femme de 14
heures de telle place j'écouterai
peut-être jean marc vallée peut-être un
peu comme dolan met aux texans fiche de
ressources comme vraiment dans la tête
l'idée dans la discothèque de jean marc
pillu te le le style oscari sur le
disque puis le tout à coup c'est une
chanson hot et un jeune dans beghetto là
est ce qu'ils vont écouter de la musique
clairement n'écouteraient pas autrement
on s'en fiche il faudrait que tu
embarques dans la mélomanie contagieuse
de jean marc vallée
pour le meilleur et pour le pays hôte et
ça ça crie ça créé une mythologie
musique yard accusée par exemple simple
inverse parce que l'église c'est
vraiment la musique qui définit la
génération c'était tel paquet
c'est comme ceux qui crient le clash en
étendant la musique comme vecteur
d'identité si c'est vraiment ce jeu
c'est la personne qui écoute du david
bowie forcément est un peu en rébellion
contre
6 seulement avec une certaine maturité
ensuite qu'on khalid c est nous on s'en
rappelle en secondaire c'est écouter du
punk le d'écouté pas durable
non mais je pense que surtout dans
l'identité adolescente la musique elle
et elle y allier allier elle est très
très très importante crise il parle
beaucoup de sous mais mais mais dans ses
oeuvres plus tardive la musique est
devienne si je devais les enfants dans
un café de flore de ce qu'ils chantent
du sigu ross ça fait aucun sens
en face jouer
on est dans le délire musical de jean
marc vallée puis même je pense qu'ils le
paroxysme de succès dans la dernière
heure complété que fait dans sharp
objects paul bérenger père qui est
justement là l'immense discothèque pays
mais ses vinyles sur les présentoirs
le disque d'alexandre estrie l'issue va
vraiment mettre ce qu'il vient en vue
plus grand label bleu le cd
mais voilà depuis pis mais moi crise
menace qui ont une énergie contagieuse
ils sont importants pour les artistes en
devenir pige en anglais moi si je peux
personnellement c'est vraiment se
soucier un de ces cinéastes québécois le
qui est vraiment un pied dans le milieu
puis un pied avec les jeunes puis la
relève pitre ici de la pousser dans le
dos puis il vraiment vraiment l'autre
même si oui on pourrait penser qu'il aux
états unis la moitié de son année mais
je pense que lorsqu'il peut revenir à
montréal puis lorsqu'il peur justement
pour nous en parler de lui me parler
pour les autres il était toujours le
il ya des moments et c'est dans quand y
faire la prospective de du temps qui
avance de la culture populaire puis il
ya des moments comme charnière puis
comme je te dirai pas ce que j'écoutais
comme plusieurs le spécial que mon ans
par jean marie aux mines plein segment
puis un des moments charnières je pense
du moins pour le cinéma québécois je
sais qu'un gros steegmans mais je pense
quand même que c'est ça c'est d'avoir
fait crazy ici avec le québec comme
trame de fond alors qu'il y avait quand
même l'option de l'exporter ailleurs
de l'adapter aux états unis parce que
moi j'ai tout or die puis deux puis mots
croisés c'est mon premier contact avec
jean marc vallée j'avais pas écouter les
autres choses qu'ils arrêtent avant
c'est beaucoup plus ni chez quand même
fallu que je vois quand même assez
craqué pour
paul près que dix ans avant le ton
premier film liste noire samedi le film
qui avait fait le plus d'entrées stany
lomé mais cette infirmation de recherche
pour l'époque mais quiz ici là c'est
l'autre j'ai toujours dit que si je
voulais amener quelqu'un me demandait de
moi un un cd puis un film pour présenter
le québec prenne gens voyageant vers
elle tombe de jean leloup pis crazy
parce que je trouvais que ça
représentait tellement
le québec le dilemme party de noël
l'ambiance des fêtes le tipi tout cela
ensemble je me dis serait tellement été
dommage que ça se fasse dans un autre
contexte tellement tellement ben oui
puis c'est pas juste et toi qu'il dit ou
moi ou nous mêmes ils ont on est forts
des fois sur les palmarès les films
québécois marc l'un des dix dernières
années ou peu importe et les fameuses
listes j'adore les livres seront les
bonnes portes d'entrée pour creuser pu
découvrir deux films d oeuvres d valable
petit quizz y est nommé tout le temps
parmi les films québécois piscicole de
sahorre film qui est profondément
généreuse pas non plus juste un film
peut-être pour la critique si je peux
créer de faux c'est le mec mais quand
même on parle d'un film qui rallie
réellement un certain grand public puis
un cinéphile peut-être plus loin du
crazy cesser complètement un pont ces
oeuvres là ils sont hyper importante
part importante parce qu'on ne devient
pas cinéphile avec des oeuvres très
pointu je dirais prend toujours des
ports d'entrée porte d'entrée puis
crise' ça peut être une double porte
entrisme pas d'entrée vers le cinéma
québécois pour bien des gens est une
porte d'entrée pour un cinéma
plus plus peut-être je veux pas ce n'est
comme si je crachais sur un certain
meanstream et quand même si c'est un
cinéma un peu plus plus poussées sur bt
avec eux puis avec une pâte avec une
griffe unique d'auteur le si on pense
qu'on peut dire puis cccd voie orale des
films comme ça qu'ils rallient les deux
leaders offrant un mémo cité le que ce
film là si mon souvenir le plus lointain
d'un film québécois que je me dis oui
c'est possible de faire des films comme
ça au québec et je n'avais jamais vu un
film d'une emploi comme cela est un film
aussi fort aussi les gens aussi c'est
grandiose qui apparaît aussi des sait
jamais on a d'abord on a entendu des
tonnes du gong stand où des tonnes de
tubes de pink floyd qui date et la
musique que j'écoutais à 14 un
film québécois puisque tout fait à
reconnaître dans le personnage principal
mais aussi vie des enfants que j'ai pas
vécu pantoute même plein d'autres
espions se reconnaît atypique justement
le modèle de la famille québécoise les
deux
de mère aimante un peu marre paul ii par
un prof de deux frères que jamais entre
autres je pense que un des succès de ce
film là c'est que on est une méchante
gagne à être connu un bien pied dans le
folklore québécois est quand même
effectivement puis c'est vrai je
comprends ce que tu désires part ça
aurait été dommage de le perdre c'est
vrai parce que l'histoire je dois
maintenant l'histoire de deux axes des
coûts sur une homosexualité à travers le
film c'est comme wii fit wii c'est
universel mais selon moi la force du
film réside pas dans ce c'est un des
aspects du film d'après moi selon moi ça
ne réside pas dans ce plan réside dans
quelque chose qui aurait pu être fait
ailleurs timos que ce qui est inspirant
d'anciens bleus c'est une certaine une
volonté d'être généreux j'ai nommé
dollars un peu plus tôt mme et ici je
peux juste faire un parallèle entre ces
deux artistes de la cie les artistes qui
ont décomplexé un certain
d'intellectualisme de spas ou une
sobriété qui peut être inquiété un petit
pitch dre de fin des années 2000 début
2010 dans le cinéma québécois le thé le
fameux cliché le du cinéma québécois un
petit cri seulement le réalisme
suicidaire mais moins qu'ils aient comme
quelqu'un qui avait écrit ces mots pour
qualifier certaines franges de cinéma
québécois mais on n'est vraiment pas là
devant chez valve et puis c'est cette
volonté d'être généreux cette volonté de
donner du spectacle ou
un petit nice à lens
c'est ça s'en prend des cinéastes
insolente puis norco equity c'est sûr
que ça fait l'important puis moi je me
rappelle encore une fois sur un autre
personnel on était en compétition de
natation j'avais deux mondes 2005 2010
ici et j'étais assez jeune je me
rappelle un soir avec ti plein de
jarnages en radeau cool on a regardé
crise id avec quel autre film québécois
on aurait pu dans une chambre d'hôtel de
compétition entre ados ont regardé un
film québec où il sera rejoint tout
autour d'eux seuls c'est ce qu'assurait
c'est plat de votre film non mais
exactement exact inverse personnes qui
rit non plus du fait que ces main stream
qui que ce soit et ben oui puis mettez
l'identité d'une marque valley est un
plan de rechange aux cités comme je
disais c'est paradoxalement c'est un des
films québécois les plus importants
peut-être des 15 années
facilement mais je veux dire on dit qu'à
la première occasion il ya quand même la
pelle des usa était dans l'oeuvre de
jean marc vallée avec des quand même
un niveau de réussite partagée est
mitigé un petit portillon victorieux de
son propre aveu tisci ans donc c'est
donc le lieu son billet d'or crise il
lui a ouvert cette porte l'offre la même
façon peut-être qu'un incendie au vert
la porte d'hollywood denis villeneuve
par exemple ou autres outils ou mamie
après ça vous alliez
km/h un peu les dents parce que le tout
à coup cette espèce de contrôler le
stress de cette grille d'auteurs dont je
parlais bas
enterrer le thé fermenté par la machine
repart façon faire absolument tirer puis
moi je les regardais aussi juste en
préparation aujourd'hui le spécial mais
je la connaissais l'histoire qui voulait
mettre du sig heureux de n'être millions
de vidéos montraient que ça me fait
rêver de ces fameux film qu'on ne verra
jamais oui j'aimerais ça le voir mon
espèce de yom victorieux là la version
son directeur il avait de la première
version qui a présenté je me rappelle
quand j'écoute est ce parce que les
hommes victorieux
quand c'est sorti
je me rappelle qu'ils avaient encaissé à
ce genre j'ai quand même ici au québec
qui était pas 100% derrière sont ni la
poussait pas tant que ça puis même sur
le plateau tout le monde en parle il dit
est ici m'entends
bien le ton film puis çà il prend un bon
cinq secondes à faire genre à waet répit
mais ça m'a fait penser pop pascal
c'était peut-être le 5 seconde langue de
bois
ces cinq secondes ces cinq secondes
c'est cette histoire là mais fait penser
une seconde que toi tu m'avais raconté
de orson welles qui avait qui avait qui
s'était fait en fit changer complètement
son son dernier film je pense s'était
alors déjà
cédé 5 m et pourquoi est un film aussi
en avance sur son temps puis aussi et
rouge en 1941 c'était puis aussi c'est
même le contrat était étrange il avait
lire le picture locke qu'on appelle donc
vraiment le réalisateur avait le droit
de regard final sur le montage
d'opérations contre dans son contrôle du
sida font exactement le kit de 26 ans
d'ailleurs pour l'anecdote incroyable
pour le film suivant l'année d'après et
qui s'appelle de minefinders
magnifique film à plein d'égards londres
et comme quelque chose cloche dans les
trous dans 20 minutes du film les yeux
vraiment quelque chose qui cloche
dramatiquement puis ça paraît et
évidemment l'histoire et que bon orson
welles qui a été mandatée est parti du
pays est allé tourner quelque chose au
brésil y revenue ces négatifs sont
disparus pour tout le dernier acte de
son film qui ont tourné une fin sans lui
laisser sentis trahis comment les
acteurs peuvent comme tourner une genre
de fins me happy ending galp garrocher
complément terrible puis il s'en est
jamais remise c'est ça
c'était en entrevue enfin une carrière
lui qui est un moment de lucidité en mai
parce qu'il était rendu vraiment alcool
et quatre fois et puis les romains
étaient rarement sa vraie personne peut
enfin se guérir une entrevue pas mené il
ya un moment qui fait genre ça me
détruit
genre 27 ans les cancers
on essaie d artistes puis des artistes
je pense venu une certaine par
définition une fragilité parfois t&d
fois il ya un frein les personnes c'est
surtout un même jean-marc vallée andrée
puis on le voit d'ailleurs l'évolution
de sa confiance en soi d'accélérer bon
déjà libre échange field était à la fois
gêné à la fin il combine nicole kidman
vient de me dire que je t'ai vraiment
d'acceptation de noémie les tiki comme
le dollar
elle vient complètement complètement
mais ouais c'est ça mais derrière des
fois cette façade le yoyo
moi je moi je pense que ça ne peut-être
qu'après sauce pour ce qui est fait dans
le club avec six fois moins de temps
alors que lyon victorieux je pense que
moins de sous et galp être plus de
liberté de longues années on se la pose
la question de son époque tous capable
d'avoir le compromis à la mi 2009 c'est
incroyable parce que tu peux juste
incroyable fmdi fait c'est incroyable
d'être capable
tu le vois on dirait un commande ou
escayol compromis puis ou qu'est ce
qu'il vous faut il dit je vais être
ultra geek dans le langage des aliens
leu leu leu leu saint denis villeneuve
le asperger ultra geek qui comme il y va
à fond puis à la géopolitique pilibo les
méchants et comme un petit côté un peu
plus 1 4 il veut tout comme monty qu il
est capable et regarde ce jeu le donneur
mais ce que ce que moi ce qui me pose
garde ce qui me tient watchguard qui me
tient à coeur en l'occurrence contre le
côté de langage le bon film cameron mais
ça c'est pas tout le monde qui est
capable de faire de draguer un pour moi
un pour heures puis je capable de faire
une oeuvre entièrement satisfaisante en
compromettant finalement surtout comme
le mali l'impression que c'est
clairement le fait qu'ils montrent ces
films prouve que il aime ça avoir un
certain contrôle 60 et justement les
choix musicaux sur le montage sur tout
ça ça parait et émettant sillage ré
écouter ou réécouter café en fait je
dis que j'ai réécouté café de flore d'un
café de flore mouche troc est la chose
la plus impressionnante de lancer mon
tracé de montastruc kurdes et un grand
sous-estimer ce même le moi je
finis sensorielle mairie on va continuer
à apprécier la filmographie
est médium victoria effectivement moi je
me rappelle l'avoir écouté puis elle m'a
dit je postule ce que je regarde c'est
pas parce que je pose je pense parce que
je suis supposé vous remet aux yeux de
hollywood c'est pas un échec un puits
même 110 par word aux costumes elle
c'est comme la halle
c'est un échec le allende à gorki
j'imagine bon j'ai pas évidemment les
chiffres le long n'a pas tiré puis on a
pris nos papiers mais même si j'imagine
c'est plus sûrement en créant son argent
même donc possiblement artistiquement
peut-être qu'ils n'y étaient pas assouvi
métier ça lui a pas fermé la porte
d'hollywood comme cela mais bref qui
existent peut-être encore quelque part
une version rampling euros ce que jean
marc valleur monter quelque part sur une
boîte de production ce serait incroyable
grâce à ce que le gras
mais bon puis mais même à table on parle
de café de flore mais moi je peux faire
un petit topo c'est ce que fait donc
trois que trois courts métrages dans les
années 90 premiers premier long métrage
liste noire mais c'est parce que je veux
je le mentionnais parce que c'est
vraiment un film québécois c'est pas mal
le film le plus d'américains des films
québécois le test un genre de thriller
bon vieux michel côté de juin geneviève
brouillette joue une prostituée qui
remet une liste le balayage scandale
parce qu'un juge de la cour d'appel qui
se fait pincer avec la prostituée mello
coup de théâtre au procès elle remet une
liste avec tous les grands hommes les
grands les utilisons une influence avec
qui et le coucher puis la lazio
d'autres avocats le saphir ont tué leur
fille contre compte complètement pied
des meurtres un bon gros gros sa sortie
c'est vraiment c'est en quoi tu ton
époque médecins se sent déjà comme la
base puis il ya un côté avec le travail
que les acteurs dans ce moulin qui passe
déjà c'est bien
plus inégal on est loin de crise' mais
pour un premier long
ça se tient sur ses pattes comme aux
antilles mais ensuite qu'il ya plein de
gens qui savent pas c'est qu'il a été
faire deux films aux étangs lui pouvoir
était quand je disais aux ex aïssa il
prend un ticket puis ensuite au ont fait
le vert par les us et y est allé faire
de film mais qui sont somme toute très
anonyme le los locos puis loire et j'ai
même oublié le titre
est donc et il en parlait lors de cette
fameuse conférence à concordia qui
m'avait mis des étoiles dans les yeux il
avait dit qu il est un peu crise la
quarantaine un prix ce qui moi pis c'est
qu'est-ce que jcs qu'est ce que moi j'ai
à dire aussi l'idée du scénario aussi
ses cci a passé des années à écrire ce
scénario là mais à mettre beaucoup
beaucoup de bons c'est aussi avec le co
scénariste de soleil lequel l'histoire
histoire de base de mon accord mais mais
on sent le coeur et le côté personnel de
son film puis je pense que ça s'est
ensuite c'est ce qu'il ne quitte jamais
c'est à dire ça peut être des univers
qui connaît pas nécessairement qui va te
connaître par la force des choses dans
la leur ce club entre le côté
l'activisme authority du site depuis le
club de son propre aveu il dit moi
vendre le scénario je connaissais rien
de ce milieu là de la même façon que je
pense que c'est comme cela pour à peu
près tous les scénarios subséquents mais
on sent que la porte d'entrée de tous
ses films ses deux quand même trouvé le
coeur c'est je pense que ça a peut-être
été la leçon d'humilité de ces de ses
premières tentatives qui pique aux
eyzies leurs peurs et et voilà puis moi
et on arrive au grand sous-estimer sa
filmographie moindre effet de force et
par rapport à ce papa parcours et par
rapport à ses débuts ce que je trouve
beau je trouve que nous mettons dans la
première entrevue qui donne en 2006 il
dit si ça faisait longtemps je fais de
la pub chez nous comme elle en 12 ans je
me trouvais loser les losers qu'on se
dit
j'arrête ou je me consacre à mon projet
auquel je crois où il a pu continuer à
faire des commandes la faire et comment
faire un peu de pub puis probablement
qui peut-être que ça restait un
réalisateur somme toute on dit mais
anonyme
piste et s'est mis à aligner prise de
slips fait leur dire que je me consacre
à mon projet puis somme toute est de
connaître
des premiers grands succès mettant dans
la quarantaine une boîte pour un artiste
souvent quand même temps son combat les
artistes sinon je trouve que ça donne
quand même bah oui mais les cinéastes
ont tout le complexe orson welles comme
disait bien laisser ses émissions le
complexe mozart août à un pote et
comment as tu es là aussi on fait
tellement d'affaires il te retrouves
dont perdant non lauzon ça peut être
facile justement parce que tu piges
écoutez notre podcast aussi pizzetti et
je faisais beaucoup peu parce qu'il ya
man il faut vivre
ça peut être de n'importe quel artiste
sa pétition musique ans nemo en
littérature quoi que ce soit ça souvent
quand rentrer là dedans ce parce que ton
grave et le comment de gaulle est
quelque chose que tu veux faire sacrer
qui brûle c'est comment on parle de
statistiques tantôt il s'adresse aux
minorités ceux qui vont réellement
mettons atteindre cette espèce de truc
le de vouloir créer une oeuvre mettons
qui va être marquante ou se met ça peut
être facile justement dahmani titre
retrouve dans l'espèce deux
quotidiens de la vie plus flipper les
offres ne manquent pas des
contre-performances hausse a défini la
chose principale qui tombera peu à peu
comme prendre place de moins en moins
vrai sens à lui de dire qu'il ya 40 ans
de noms je ramène le bar anvers puis je
le réalise mon fait que tu trouves lui
fera que ça fait dix ans que j'écris
quelque chose de bombes de louis xi qui
est michel côté est côté
kitsch et à suite à la mort de jean m'a
fait aller il est allé à une émission de
télé matin le carré matisse
or depuis liste noire il n'arrêtait pas
de me dire michel j'ai un scénario le
tüv a capoté et à chaque fois ça
commence pas le bon moment sur le bon
timing est pas prêt ce problème peut
amener à met à rêver fait gelé le que
lui il a fallu qu'ils disent qu'ils
fassent au québec seulement par le pij
très curieux aussi le lire le par
rapport au scénario tunisie le jeu mais
sûrement éclaté j'ai dix ans mais pas de
contrainte
d'après ce que j'ai ramené six mais
j'aurais cru devoir et
15 millions que les élèves n'ont déjà
alors il ya eu 7 millions au fac aux
eyzies en 2005
mais mais mais bon budget était jésus
quand même tourné sont fait manger aux
23 24 ou 25 je ne sais pas le surgelé
pas la stat mais ce
faux toujours toujours toujours
maximiser ses poursuivants que les
cinéastes québécois ils ont la cote
après hollywood c'est quand denis
villeneuve est justement incendie puis
que le monde à lourdes en fait m et 8
millions pour faire ce genre
fait nous la meilleure affaire c'est ça
c'est je pense que c'est une des forces
c'est effectivement très inventif et à
maximiser mettre l'argent l'écran alors
à son plein potentiel parlant de ceux
ensuite toute la phase qui le fait avec
yves bélanger le t2 das bars clubs et
jusqu'à sharp object il en parle comme
ma soeur on parle pas mal de son modus
operandi de dire nature et ça c'est ceux
de tournai effectivement de focaliser
sur l'acteur de ne pas en quarts cannes
et des acteurs dans des mises en place
lourde vraiment
très 3 360 degrés et souvent l'épaule en
lumière disponible et mémé c'est avec
yves bélanger vraiment il ya un travail
en tandem à partir de l'eau parce qu'il
est ils avaient des directeurs photo aux
différents à chaque film avant dallas
buyers club et puis l'europe tout à coup
il ya comme une alchimie comme quelque
chose qui était capable de faire
peut-être parce que tu es je veux pas
prêté l'intention mais peut-être parce
que en fait ça nous donne juste le
matériel pour s'éclater aussi au montage
on le sent que c'est là où je pense
qu'il a vraiment un langage puis moi je
pense même que jean marc vallée jarry
qu'elle était curieux qui théorisent ces
jo de londres est qu'il ya une partie
moi qui rêve de deux livres où il sur le
montage louis peut vraiment on peut
rentrer dans sa tête où il théorise
parce qu'il y aura une technique jean
marc gallet jeudi en titrant paul on
regarde gérer pour compléter ma
filmographie valley j'avais pas vu
chaque objet que je les regardais le
récemment puis première scène les
premières quelques plans un livre lâche
la genre de poésie fragmenté sa façon
comment ils traitent justement le le
rail le présent le passé et amalgames
tous ses combats c'est jean marc vallée
au montage c'est officiel nice seror ça
c'est rare aurore qu'on est capable de
le reconnaître un artiste par par la
coupe la dernière présence à tout le
monde en parle j'en ris parle justement
du montage fait que c'est lui qui fait
tout comme genre il parle à quel point
le montage est une simple lettre
d'anissa question c'est affectueux tu
maîtrises les et logiciels
ça fait rigoler mais la question est
intéressante parce que pour moi un pur
montage c'est pourtant lui qui cliquent
le plus veinard bonbons tard ça peut
être
mécaniquement comprendre comment ces
bulles de temps le peuvent créer une
alchimie télé le fameux effet coulé
chevelu comment justement au presbytère
de
données ainsi différents en fonction de
leur jeu mon bref jean marc vallée mais
il ya comme une poésie aussi dans son
montage mais en même temps on n'est pas
non plus en train d'imiter un terrain ce
mal et qu'on n'est pas en train de
pleurer porte le jeu peut nommer
d'autres cinéastes c'est vraiment
quelque chose c'est ça touche à lui 10e
quand on y pense et on a trop peu permet
trop peu surtout qu'ils ont des loges
comme ça mainstream techniques
d'aujourd'hui c'est le où il ya vraiment
le moule comme une façon relativement
anonyme de filmer des images et de
conseil on consomme énormément d'image
qui sont un peu formaté
c'est clair puis c'est fou de se rendre
là en étant constamment conscient de des
formes atterrissement chute libre assez
de créer un autre forme de langage mais
qui soit tout de même très généreux et
communicatif c'est impressionnant ses
seules plus impressionnables on ne
reviendrait qu'à qu'on va parler de big
lots
l'allemagne pour moi c'est la plus belle
chose qui s seul le plus impressionnant
c'est comme d'arrivée avec dans un
format super meanstream puis de faire de
quoi que tu sens tout de suite qui est
différent et grandement mai et ont été
rendues
dans canal j puis ça tombait comme peu
comme parlementaires sans justement
parce que moi je trouve doit l'avoir
écouté hier je fais jusqu'à matane
mettons de me dire ok ce film l'homme et
on a avec un une ligne du temps linéaire
de la main mais tant pis sans mettons
l'inclusion de la musique notre film le
pis ce fameux le parlement me fait me
ferez pas grand chose mais il ya
vraiment quelque chose dans ce film je
sais pas c'est quoi au juste pourquoi là
parce que je me souviens c'est fait
j'avais juste ça m'avait vraiment
bouleversée vraiment vraiment touché
puis j'ai regardé hier puis honnêtement
j'ai jambes magnifiques
comme non-stop l'influent un flot
constant beaucoup de films je passe
beaucoup par le son et la musique c'est
vraiment ce parce que
moi le son la musique commence et
commence avec lui via avec image bien t
il il ya vraiment des longs moments last
fm le qui sait que de l'image puis ce
montage du tout une séquence au début
qu'il ya pratiquement pas dialogue
pratiquement pas non plus deux c'est
comme si une exposition peu des
personnages mais le maillot vraiment
vraiment dans l'observation mais
c'est moche trop ce magistral comment
s'est fait ce fait même le pire pis si
ça s'arrête plus à être quelqu'un
d'autre justement derrière les pitas
nages derrière g2 le montage vesa dépôt
donné si on n'a pas créé espèce
d'alchimie le dont j'ai vraiment comme
je
l'avais lyon verge ans d'éléments qui
fait qu'ils aient commis quelque chose
me suis d'accord c'est un film qui est
infiniment meilleur que son synopsis en
blanc c'est comme l'histoire de ce mets
ton jeu capable de café de flore à
quelqu'un qu'il ne l'aurait pas vu je
pourrais mouiller le synopsis ou peu
importe mais ça ça ça rend pas justice
je pense que c'est quand même on est
quand même proche d'une certaine forme
d'un film expérience nous sommes
un pis mais moi ce qui m'avait aussi
frappé c'était que parfois les films qui
sont formellement
justement éclaté tous ceux souvent il ya
une fâcheuse tendance à ce que ce soit
au détriment d'une connexion humaine
café de flore je trouve que c'est pour
moi ce qui m'a marqué pourquoi je trouve
que c'est un peu un incompris un peu mal
aimé je me comprends pas trop pourquoi
mais parce que moi c'est que je trouve
que l'humain passe malgré tout c'est ça
en fait la grande force d'un café de
flore à mes yeux c'est que oui le
contenant et très stylé stylisée mais
mais mon dieu il ya quand même des
performances d'acteurs j'aime le dr
d'actrice une émotion qui vit clé c'est
comme si tout cet excès de zèle
stylistique mais sert profondément le
fils et son récit d'une histoire d'amour
une histoire d'amour tout le temps tout
est casse gueule parce que ça peut sur
l'amour peut facilement verser dans
d'autres quittaient la différence en
quelque chose de vraiment touchant
pilc et ncc
la victime ou c est ce que est ce que
j'y crois bien ce que je ressens les
émotions bien qu'intéressant potes et
juste battre ici c'est comme on très
facile à dire qu arte ou facile à
l'homme
dénigrer mais ton métier quand que quand
ça réussit à faire vibrer cette corde
lieu de l'émotion ce que mouassa russie
en est-il de femmes le fait de ressentir
c'est là la peine ce personnage
qui vit
une peine d'amour immense lundi la
comprendre puis de la victime puis même
moi mettons d'abord jamais vraiment
véhicules sont à ce point le jeu peut
quand même comprendre puisque breuil
quand même en métal sur l'astre phi phi
lui sa situation pondre et qui sait ça
réussit vraiment à nous faire ce
ressenti ce que les personnages
ressemblent le chemin en fait on en
parle depuis tantôt puis je comprends un
peu pourquoi le film et marc emig parce
que toute la l'autre histoire est moins
intéressant parce qu'ils vanessa paradis
surnaturel enfants souvent par leurs
poteaux aux médecins il ya comme quelque
chose d'ancien bloc qui est un petit
peur qu'il est inégal quand même les
deux hameçon son pote de force similaire
donc on est comme vous et à effacer avec
ce qu'ils fument parce que c'est facile
de dire qu'on en parle on en oublie
vraiment souvent le pain vanessa paradis
quand même bonne mais c'est pas à elle
que tu disposes pas elle qui était dans
un bâtiment
puis l'autre femme j'avais trouvé je me
rappelle qu'à le voir au cinéma quand
c'est sorti une dette d'ailleurs bon la
fatidique date
mais
mewen d'affaires que je me rappelais m'a
dit c'est
d'avoir eu un centime j'étais content
qu'il revienne au québec du décompte ans
qui se réinstallent ici j'étais content
de retrouver les codes sa vision d'un
québec cette fois là évidemment c'est
même plus radicale plus moderne c'est un
sens plus contemporain parce que choisit
aux sentences des années 70 dit en
montant mais là c'est quand inquiet si
le québec dans lequel on est en ce
moment puis vous je me rappelle avoir
vraiment apprécié le fait que nous le
montre à travers ses yeux les mêmes yeux
qu'ils ont vu dans qui voyait le québec
de l'époque de cohesis mais le dans le
contemporain et je trouve que c'était
vraiment bien racisme puis on sent
peut-être un retour du balancier total
com utilise c'est peut-être son film
formellement le plus radical même mêmes
incluant le ce qui vient après
café de flore il ya quelque chose les
jusqu'au boutisme dans la démarche qui
est assez frappante c'est qui peut
larguer certaines personnes mais je
pense que si on s on embarque dans la
routine un film qui traite beaucoup de
valeur le jeu trouble c'est que c'est
quand même c'est quand même
un beau move de caste et keven par an
voilà sa carrière fait pour le moins
agacé aujourd'hui
mais
ils marchent pas
c'est ça mais c'est quand même un bon
pari puis je me rappelle aussi dans pour
clore café de flore ah oui bat-il crise'
déjà c'est le titre est une chanson au
café de flore l'artiste est une chanson
on est instantanément comme je parlais
de mythologie musicale jusque dans le
titre de ces faits melons sont peut pas
se méprendre l'oeil est allé avec son
sigur ros qui voulait depuis
quitté la musique est tellement qu on
appelle ça un treuil et digestive
film les personnages chantent en même
temps il ajouté lol la musique on
attendait pourtant j'entends aussi fait
que c'est après ceux ci comme pape le
montage
je pense qu'elle est au scénario et je
veux dire qu'en ne faut pas que je me
compare mettait plus à vos moi aussi je
capable de dire quand même assez
dentelle c'est joli mais au scénario les
chansons que j'étais souvent on pense un
peu en images et en sons ayant et en
musique et en rythme quand même sinon il
n'y avait pas de sigur ros d'antan
oui non non c'est simplement m'étais
dernière chose que ce soit sur le café
de flore mais c'est que je me rappelle
il le fera en deux temps il ya quand
même quelque chose de très
grandes il a k'un au niveau de la
production mais il ya beaucoup de
moments il part intime pigeons jean marc
vallée a dit m tony je pense dans cette
cathédrale notre-dame et il n'y avait
pas le droit puis c'est juste pointer
avec sa caméra ds alors la sacem dépit
le fait pêcheurs je me rappelle il y
avait raconté sauter devant donc une
fois le jeune étudiant en moi je te
comprends ma gueule ces gens ont fait
des choix par exemple dans la chambre
d'hôtel c'est tout genre juste jean marc
vallée avec deux parents n'y a même pas
de preneurs de sons tout le son est reçu
avec sa caméra ds et à leurs tee pee moi
j'étais comme ah mais c'est ce allée
louis à leur écoute c'est la meilleure
caméra pour ton film c'est la caméra qui
va donner ta chute piste eu besoin de
voler quelque chose c'est à l'aide d'un
appareil photo mais pourquoi potes et je
me dis puissant gros film the simpsons
quand même
jean marc vallée au volet des chocs dans
la l'église notre avec 5000 clairement
il ya pris goût parce qu'après ça c'est
devenu son style j'aime aller à aleppo
les armes à facteurs
c++ devenu une espèce de on capte le
moment qui se passe puisque on s'est
appelé quittions la note parfaite oui je
pense que tout est à force de faire son
montage et finit par savoir exactement
la matière brute parce que une image
peut être un peu entre gros guillemets
une intéressante en soi mais je pense
que l'iran du lot il rendu tellement en
possession de ses moyens au niveau de ce
qui ce qui est fait faire au montage que
ça lui permet donc cette espèce de ses
élans le ensuite le il ya clairement le
matériel qu'ils aux besoins pis c'est
comme aller chercher mais c'est s'appuie
le poumon après après il ya la phase iib
bélanger comme je te dis de dallas ce
club jusqu'à la fin et le lion jean marc
vallée il ya un style qui peut plus
uniforme [ __ ] mais mais les sujets
sont toujours très très différente c'est
moi ça m'impressionne ces cinéastes
locaux qui vont pas décemment femme
après film creuser dans les mêmes dans
le même puisque tout à coup tout ayant
un peu forcé à devenir un expert d'un
sujet ex uni direct parce que le bal
matériel
si price puis bah t'as pas le choix de
faire de la recherche peut pas voir
leurs deux pics sur la latte au bond
mais pire encore une fois de son propre
aveu jean galy dim qui connaissait pas
vraiment stylé les courants aux états
unis dans les années 80 au type pour par
exemple si des leçons et colas par le
club comme ça lucky ce qu'ils se mettent
à niveau puis à ce sujet moyens il ya un
article très intéressant que j'ai lu
récemment où le scénario était pas sans
faille en haut niveau 2 il y avait il à
zte à la faillite il dit la dronne en
question le présenter les questions
beaucoup kiki kaki très dommageable bon
mais à lattes et à la fin ils ont dû feu
me disent quand même que maintenant le
has été dosés d'autres façons tu es à
sauver des vies parce qu'il y avait
comme une des co scénariste qui est un
peu qu'ils étaient sur des théories qui
est un petit peu à côté de la plaque
qu'il ya des activistes qui il a fait
lire le scénario d activisme à quelques
semaines du tournage puis là il ya eu
des gros drapeau rouge en
6e film le scénario les tournées comme
ce tu vas avoir le plus gros bâclage de
l'entente a noté t de tout le monde
élève des activistes le compléter pour
le site de dreux et puis jean marc
vallée donc en catastrophe et des appels
conférences pillot com com qui avait
effectivement une des deux co scénariste
qui ont un peu écarté par comme les
salaires comme un peu cheap une vision
problématiques
comme lui ce beau contre typo
pour utiliser une drogue qui peut
approuver les territoires des comme ça
marche sur ces sujets de la beauce puis
avait réussi des trucs très pragmatique
avec le personnage de jared leto aussi
un hippie bon bref et
il ya vraiment une superbe déboulé
complètement le scénario pis à trois
semaines leurs pires et des projections
tests avec l'amendé étaient des
activistes des gens influents dans le
milieu pour un peu avant le sceau
d'approbation des gens qu'on n'est pas
ici on peut pas avoir deux pics leur
présenter un monde que tu connais pour y
arriver qu'un esprit un peu colonisateur
de comment on va exploiter la misère
puis le folklore de l'histoire de
quelque chose non têtu tu leur dois
quelque chose
ils vont et toute une époque est bref
mais pour dire que c'est je pense que si
c'était coûte le que jean marc vallée a
amené un film qui aurait plu c'est un
film notamment un grand succès dans
mario là se faisait passer
d'un même prénom me refusais scénario un
peu partout les
mots quand quelqu'un qui a été annoncé
je m'appelle j'ai vu le trailer pour la
première fois genre que les steaks a
annoncé mathieu mes conneries et jared
leto petit l argument de vente c'est s
es et l estomac même d'acteurs en a mais
perdu 45 lits mais après ça parce que
moi à ce moment-là je me dis quand même
un gros film hollywoodien c'est avec
deux gros acteurs j'aurais il doit avoir
débloqué le budget gelé penser jusqu'à
récemment jeté changer quand on a appris
que c'était 5 millions qui nous est à 5
millions il y avait certes pour crazy
bien 5 millions 5 millions ces gens
c'est que c'est pas beaucoup dans le
contexte d'un film de que tu fais de a à
z en 5 millions dans son combat
les comédies romantiques qui faisait
avant cela doit-être son cachet ça ne
m'atteint 5 millions autre coup c'est
assez dans ce chiffre le jeu ne savent
pas qu'on s'en fout cc c'est incroyable
puis puis après ça si tu le sais parce
qu'elle les réalisateurs souvent il ya
beaucoup de direction d'acteur dans la
réalisation le fait même si des acteurs
ils sont excellents et même beaucoup de
direction d'acteurs je pense que dallas
buyers club c'est un bon moment pour
parler de la direction d'acteurs parce
que ces films-là gagné 2 au score mais y
aura d'abord puis le meilleur acteur de
soutien ça c'est aussi intimement lié au
réalisateur ferment ou peut-être métier
si je peux faire parler le disons avec
ma propre réflexion sur le travail que
les acteurs des jeux direction d'acteur
je toussais autoritaires comme comme
appellation je
collabore avec l'acteur c'est pipi je
sais que jean marc vallée oui ce 2 de ce
que j'entends de tout ça évidemment j'ai
jamais été un observateur sur ses
plateaux mais quand même je connais bien
ses films sa démarche mais est il fait
pas beaucoup de répète et pitt il faut
le dire y jouit métayer pas constamment
il n'essaie pas de modeler l'acteur dans
quelque chose de sa région sua sa vision
c'est complètement le touché qui laisse
quand même beaucoup de de placer les
gens les bons acteurs une fois que tu es
au cast et ils arrivent sont prêts le en
général c'est très rock et a ramené une
scène à 180° parce qu'elle marchait
vraiment pas en général l'acteur un bon
instinct quand même si ensuite on les
accompagne on les guide on a une vision
d'ensemble t-il le réalisateur à la
vision d'ensemble que l'acteur n'aurait
jamais dans un sens mais mais je sais
que c'est aussi soit dit j'ai entre
guillemets un acteur c'est de la
compagnie c'est de lui faire confiance
je pense que parce qu'un acteur qui
n'est pas en confiance je pense que
c'est un acteur qui devient si tu es fou
site est un acteur qui cherche qui sait
pas trop qui est consciente lui même qui
doute ça c'est peut-être pas une recette
vers le succès ce que je veux dire c'est
que je sais qu'il est apprécié de ses
acteurs puissent eux ça c'est la clé
peut-être moi je pense que juste d'être
de prêtres indique le puits d'être
apprécié travailler les respecte et
lipides et des gens intelligents pis on
va dans le même sens ensemble juste sur
le thé dans la bonne moitié des rasoirs
pour diriger des acteurs puis je suis
gentil j'écoutais évelyne brochu parler
d'eux des cafés flotte et puis de
travailler comme en valais puis à disait
qu' il était vraiment
il y avait beaucoup de discussions avec
sur le personnage c'est vraiment en
dehors de la scène la direction des
caprices comme ceux plus comme ça c'est
vraiment c'est qui ton personnage est
petit est jusqu'à l'état tout du
personnage si cool earth communication
lesquels tu arrives en premier c'est
vraiment d'aller dans les micro détails
pour que je pense que créer les
conditions pour que l'acteur connaissent
le mieux possible son personnage qui a
parlé aussi de sur le plateau mais c'est
pas ce plateau confesse aux parents mais
c'est avant il est grand sur le plateau
c'était beaucoup plus le travail qu'il
faisait c'était beaucoup plus créer un
monde pour que on ne te montre la bonne
taille pour la fatigue c'est tout en lui
c'est tout le temps lui qui était le dj
ce plateau le titre acquis mettons entre
les cotes métayage east pendant que les
techniciens ya juste l'éclairage mais
jean marc vallée mais la bonne tenue
pour que tout le monde soit dans le bon
mode pour la prochaine
beaucoup plus créer une largeur de
psychologie de l'agent de mettre les
gens en confiance mettre les gens ici le
maître de cérémonie mais oui
vraiment mail pis le plateau de tournage
le réalisateur le temps performance puis
je dis pas ça parce que tu te mets pas
un masque si tu étais toi même mais moi
moi ça avec qui je dîne aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous est-ce que je suis avec
mes acteurs est ce que je prends est-ce
que je suis pas dans mon coin ce que je
ne me reste que je suis avec les la
technique c'est qu'on le met genre c'est
quand même des choses qu'ils on lance
des messages constamment ti ccpo c'est
un trip d'ego faire un film c'est vrai
que ces cultures collaborer mais reste
que si on fait une analogie de bateaux
le titre que le capitaine sarrès le
réalisateur et les yeux dit qu'un petit
problème vous pouvez ou peu importe les
bacs surtout donc si toi tu es un stress
qui est vraiment qui irradie d'une façon
qui paralyse vers ses doigts oui tout le
monde viendra 6 d'autres c'est une
mauvaise journée tout le monde a une
mauvaise journée donc pour ce que dit
super forme dans un sens qui est dit des
fois faut faire le
l'examen de conscience qui désire qu'il
le faut que je fasse il faut le prendre
sur moi faut je devrais faire ça pour
que le bateau est dans le bon sens mais
bref c'est vraiment un test des
capacités de leadership coli du patin
oui c'est ce pee wee mettre la musique
c'est drôle encore le ça me surprend pas
je l'avais pas entendue celle-là mais
chez moi même je fais s'appuie sûr qu'il
aura la même chose me mettez moi je fais
est décédé le bain chez school si grave
est décédé météo des playlists sorti
fédérer
ça paraît trop c'est tous des petits
détails qui fait je te donne tout se
vend dans ton coin avec ce sam acer s'il
ya quelque chose qui qu'il est l'acteur
bien rentrer un peu dans ta tête dans ce
que tu aimes de ce que tu aimerais du
personnage et ensuite sur la vie et sur
le plateau puis l'on peut être plus
pragmatique parce que ce pull talons
psychanalyse par le passé du personnage
en cela sur un plateau sur l'analogie
c'est sûr sur un éboulement l'été tout
va vite et décision et prends beaucoup à
l'instinct c'est peut pas commencer à
blablater et gemalto 7 mais quand on
crée le buzz créé l'atmosphère est
vraiment créer une bonne atmosphère mais
j'ai pris soin des enfants c'est
tellement vrai que les enfants si toi tu
es stressé l'enfant et stressés ils ont
exposé c'était le premier à performer
mais c'est fou mais ce qui est
impressionnant c'est d'avoir
la confiance d'arriver sur des plateaux
avec des acteurs de renommée
internationale et petit levi les plus
grands quand même d'arriver c'est toi
qui tentent d'étendre son leadership ce
fonds peut pas montrer des signes de
rechute intime départ toi chaque mot 6
quand je pense justement à ce gala qui
vaut aux états unis puis dirigé grands
acteurs des accords avec il les oraux
les plus ils plus grande c'est pisser
comme
j'arrive c'est moi qui moi qui le chef
si
pour pas que je montre des signes de
cash intime dès que je suis pas ma place
ça ça prend quand même des
nicolas oui je l'aï vu oui complètement
j'imagine mettez tout tous les acteurs
le dise ou presque indépendamment de
leur statut les sommes soient être être
guidé accompagné dirigé
au final c'était la même affaire
avec sa soeur nicole kidman que ce soit
ce quelqu'un contenant des grands c'est
la même chose bah oui tipi pied puis on
l'a on la sent la magie était des fois
c'est mystérieux mais comme quand ça
parce qu'ils manquent quelque chose je
peux utiliser les termes et ôté rythme
était une électricité qui passe les
collections akilov devrait on le
véhicule gens on vient de dire coupé
puis comme à qui on a vécu un moment le
collectivement quelque chose d'un peu
religieux dans cette expérience le
parfois tu es sur tous les plans qui
devait qui sont qui sont des plans plus
musclée d'autres anti j'imagine que lors
des scènes nicole kidman et son mari
dans big little live sacramentines tu
fais pas 15 prises le ça se trouve c'est
la première et bonne taille garde parce
que carrick mais mais mais mais c'est
tombeau de créer un environnement où en
traction peut couper la bulle de temps
elle est est magique
dans les clubs c'est ce qui me manquait
certes ils étaient des centaines
tellement forte genre entre les acteurs
des interactions tellement une scène que
me cache de sortie de ce n'est moi
j'étais sur le cul non le web à
l'adresse club c'est drôle je lis
pourrez visiter depuis sa sortie c'est
quoi 2013 dans le ps club je me rappelle
beaucoup du stolt des acteurs qui ont
gagné 10 tonnes si je passe au négatif
pour autant mais c'est parce que je
pense la promo été fait beaucoup à
succès c'était vraiment comme c'est
matthew mcconaughey le c40 les
exactement on dit que c'est peut-être ce
dont je me rappelle plus fécondes et
c'est peut-être le film de tout ce qu'on
va parler que ggg part de l'interférence
de mon appréciation du film je me
rappelle j'ai vraiment aimé semaine
la dent dans un podcast que j'écoutais
justement qui est la marque valais puis
il parlait de script et de mettre mes
qualités pizza hut à revel est bon signe
a chuté puis le lui il porte plomb il
dit moi pour l'équipe pense à regarder
mais justement c'était le directeur
photo qui y ont comme un moment de
phoques genre il joue ben trop jeune
trop grosjean semaine le caricatural
il étudie iman physiquement on s'est
éloigné on fait des plans plus larges
parce que en close-up c'était comme tout
moi ça devenait trop ça implose avait
affirmé il ya un danger c'est soit 6 e
puis il dit j'ai eu c'est ridicule
inquiétude le toulon puis qui t'arrive
au montage regard des images préfète
crise il ya deux raisons sa masse est
parfait si fous pareils d'avancé puisque
points d'avancé toutes les pistes
lamentait rendre compte que annonce est
exactement pipi en plus je sais pas lui
physiquement et où sur un plateau mais
yo yo yo yo peut vivre une expérience
crissement différents tant pis
d'ailleurs c'est pour ce qu'on filme
toujours une audition parce que des fois
il ya quelque chose de qui ce passe
comme humainement parlant puis le tueur
garde l'image qu'ils étaient filmés et
comme des fois ça amplifie vers le haut
mieux ou au pire quelque chose que tu as
vu que t'as pas vu bon bref
j'imagine qu'il doit pas être la
personne le genre de réalisateur qui
s'assoit le terme technique sera la big
show qu'on dit le tigre comme un gros
mot nord où il ya par exemple la
personne qui fait la continuité tout le
monde qui ont département à regarder
bien ils vont regarder le plus gros
moteur qui soit un petit peu plus
heureux très souvent les metteurs en
scène
mais tombe ou autre que j'aime mieux
avoir dans mon petit moniteur peut être
un peu tout seul puis proche des
comédiens au 6 mai puis à des gens même
qui qui qui vont juste regarder les
comédiens humainement qui vont pas trop
trop trop regarder l'image ça c'est
possible si c'est le genre de cinéastes
qui ne regardent pas un groupe moniteur
par exemple c'est vrai que tu peux avoir
une perception un peu forcé de ce qui
vient de se vivre c'était comme si tu
trop grosse et popi c'est mais faut
quand même faire confiance quand bien
casser la personne l'acteur il peut
arriver que des propositions réauté
intérieur dangereux pitié mais koné et
le joue un rôle
mais qui sait si j'ai braillé aussi
ça passe par ici
avec dallas boston bar ce club c'est
vraiment le redressement de sa carrière
et on met with ces combats qu'on sait
c'est que ça faisait deux ans qui
refusait toutes les demandes pour des
comédies romantiques qui faisait plus de
films plus tard ivre et plus qu'il a
comme faire ce genre salut j'ai
complètement sa direction le grand
valley était comme de ce que j'ai
entendu il postule me semble que c'est
beau gosse en karting
mais finalement c'est que ce héros que
tu ne me christiane bio parce que je
pense que la plupart des acteurs qui ont
commencé crotone courte beau gosse puis
qu'ils ont une carrière dans la durée il
ya vraiment le film kick-ass estime
agences d'intérim les 90 caprio estime
le bit et piwi match mais connaît aussi
subi la même année match mais connaît
aussi fera plus pouvoir suis tu sais il
ya un petit rôle
une 5000
communes à savoir est ce que tu as
encore dans la même chaîne que dallas y
avait plus haché
ok
mais mais mais mais bon historique main
cet argument est un film de réalisateur
québécois qui gagne deux oscars c'est
quand même
ben ouais ben là le jun ce fabre est là
la croix fin on sait pas qui est ce qui
va gagner comment mais
déjà il d'aller dans les trucs
techniques parce qu'il y ait pas eu
énormément de gros gros groupe français
accor effets spéciaux assez belle cote
si on micro par un pitbull mais mosquée
capoté dans l'une c'est que malgré le
côté massif de cette estime le
cétacé analogue ce que j'ai en tête
quand je repense à dulce des costumes
c'est justement le désert et textures
comme ccpo justement l'extravagance z
images de synthèse vraiment pas vraiment
de recherche d'une direction artistique
le rétro futuriste
design des vaisseaux
c'est fou mais le côté un peu un peu
crasseux métallique qui comme le que ça
fait longtemps le exemple quelqu'un que
la carcasse métallique are also
inversement côté cour impériale de leurs
habits a eu le dessus
mais ça a du goût en ce sens moi je
trouve que ce petit le temps nous le
dira mais j'ai l'impression qu'un film
comme ça il vous est assez bien vieillir
visuellement parlant aussi quelque chose
d'un peu intemporel dans la recherche le
plastique deux films comme ça c'est
quand même bon après je pense que ses
ouailles l'année d'après l'année d'après
les ions d'euros le ca va assez vite
puis là c'est souvent en fait les
acteurs les actrices qui y arrivent avec
des projets puis 2014 c'est aussi
l'année où il y avait émis adams qui
avait a été pendant longtemps il était
censé faire un film janis joplin avec
lui avant il ya eu des histoires de
poursuite le il ya eu des embûches légal
qui ont fait en sorte que le film il
était sur la glace jusqu'à ce qu'à
manille il ne puisse plus se faire et
que ce soir pour mort dans l'oeuf mais
mais des jeux le après dallas buyers
club c'est comme quand tu fais gagner
deux scores raté deux grosses
performances je les adore
ça tapait
dans la tête de certaines personnes
c'est correct c'est bien c'est dit jean
puis aussi ce qui est impressionnant par
exemple reese witherspoon dans le code
the world et the big little life c'est
que ce sont des actrices qui ont
vraiment pris leur carrière en mieux
lotis ce sont des productrices les
femmes d'affaires bleu sombre et c'est
ce qu'ils font le collier demain c'est
ce qu'a fait le mari de reese
witherspoon c'est le gérant
c'est comme ceux en
bas puis en prusse awards en plus je
pense que la méthodologie de tournage
qui préconisait bec entre un film soit
quelqu'un qui fait
le transpacifique le ses 1700 je pense
km de marche ben tout comme meurent plus
par choix de la suivre donc c'est un peu
vous et en lumière naturelle à l'épaule
donc moi je pense qu'il y avait comme
tête le ca fait ding ding ding mais
comme dans les deux sens et comme il va
nous arriver avec la bonne façon de
filmer pour que cela fonctionne pis le
montage lalala twist au montage mais des
chaînes la brise glace pour ça c'est
comme vous dit c'est mon plus loin tant
aimer énormément disent elles de montage
non seulement les dix plus si on
obligeait ramé - musicale mondiale d'ici
deux mois mais beaucoup parce que le
wild alors on revient dans la ligue
beaucoup on est dans la taille des
personnages du coup par la inzaghi jeu
les rictus et récemment puisse aussi
j'ai tout fait mais j'ai écouté j'ai
écouté ses trois plus simple sur le
project mais
encore une fois la musique comme étant
un personnage compliqué comme étant à
l'intérieur du film un tipi une
résonance et le deuxième en un film sur
quelqu'un qui marche mais certains
qu'ils remettent ça peut être longtemps
maintenant fromage soit bien dire que ce
soit intéressant puis je trouve que
justement la manière qui est comme on se
sent dans sa tête à elle qu'il ya des
trucs qui joue mais des fois si je sais
je chantonne un peu c'est vraiment serre
a menti tout ça à l'intérieur
non exactement c'est sorti comme une
caisse de résonance de de son émotion de
sa psyché de ça sympa ça passe pas bien
mais je me rappelle je suis way we
aurait la pression du favori mais
laisser
avoir été extrêmement déçue des
centaines d'appels de magic mile ce
genre ça va être fou son prochain c'est
sûr ça a été incroyable
je me rappelle que c'est de tous ces
films c'est c'est de loin lui qui me
laissait les mois se suivent un mois
maintenant
mais
c'est une performance beaucoup il me
laisse penser qu'il ya pas d
kloet et c'est la façon que d'en avoir
mais je me rappelle très bien sûr que ça
a été le trop cheap bénéfique le poids
qui venait qui est amené ça fait du bien
aussi parce witherspoon va un peu comme
laura dern on va y venir avec les
twilight mais ils sont sont excellentes
meilhon d'état casse beaucoup tes poule
c le bouledogue le thé la la la la socri
bob bennett un
casting à la fête souvent en fait mais
aurait cependant à peu commencé dans
l'élection d'alexander payne la fin des
années 90 ne peut sembler qui le fait
découvrir c'est cela la fille qui va
tout prix gagner son élection à l'école
qui s'est en euroligue est incroyable
c'est comme sur mesures énergiques pour
ensuite battre les galets blancs
d'étouffer bref comme une image qui est
un peu plus grande que nature à
l'arrivée quand même à y voir j'ai
l'impression que c'est pour ça que je
veux dire c'est comme si un inversement
de match mais koné qui est arrivé dans
le groupe dans la performance a grimpé
majuscule montrer que ça faisait du bien
de voir visuel est cependant une
intérieure retreat parce que cette année
on était capable de l'avoir toujours
joué les bulldogs
mais c'est sûr que si on s'est peut-être
qu'ils à l'habitude aussi à des projets
vraiment ambitieux notamment comme
breathing café de flore des trucs
vraiment quand même éclaté depuis trois
ans j'ai fait quand même un peu plus
contenue qui sobre puis ça fait entre
eux mais peut-être un petit peu quand
même mais mais mais mais moi moi
j'habite j'ai bien aimé puis ensuite
j'ai une autre grosse performance
démolition g à dori seul à
défendre un peu je l'écouté plusieurs
fois
puis à chaque fois c'est quelque chose
de nouveau qui venait me chercher là
l'intrigué principale parce que quand
même une espèce d'intérêt qui veut créer
du suspense
jugement qui s'est un peu le dessus tout
c'est la cerise ce que j'ai mais c'est
la mort
en fait c'est tout là
c'est tout l'arc du deuil
vers le film au complet me piquer comme
dans l'acte de déconstruire de démolir
les choses il fait un peu envers lui
même je trouve c'est vraiment bien fait
depuis je trouve qu'il ya vraiment des
scènes la bande qui dans ma tête ou du
moins juste pour moi sont restés icône
éclipsé par exemple qu'un kilo il se met
à écouter la playlist qui se fait donner
danse au milieu des passants mettons
dans rule soit pour moi c'est une scène
qui est incroyable c'est je trouve ça
vraiment je trouve c'est comme la
réalisation qui acceptent ce qui arrive
puis n'ont jamais su belgique gens
écoutent la même année je ne m'abuse que
baky koné faisait son run run est un
film que là on est il vraiment le
cinéaste on égalerait ya vraiment
maximiser le côté cruel
et ensuite on dirait que l'on est allé
lô avec lui on est allé lui a fait jouer
des
fêtes un film avec denis villeneuve dans
le mannequinat mais j'ai fait et 9e en
même temps oui mais lui lui a joué avec
denis villeneuve dans la fête du feu
ennemi ce qui est fait
mais j'écoutais un émigré
même ceux qui travaillent et qui les 2 g
l otan québécoise expatrient
ennemi c'est moi je me rappelle la façon
comment ils filment toronto une belle
façon de filmer la ville entre autres
piles et un souci plat final pas trop on
préfère un petit assure denis
on
lui souhaite on lui souhaite d'autre a
mis en lice ed d'autres trajets parce
que michael lui même en partie mais on
n'est pas aussi de parler longtemps de
démolition mais c'est juste que je
trouve que c'est un souhait mais que
beaucoup de monde qui n'ont pas écouté
non fille mais je me rappelle je me
rappelle chaque fois que j'ai écouté
j'ai adoré la performance de
james incroyants c'est ensuite scellé
les deux gros série du groupe i
tristement ben ce rôle et les chant du
cygne le
pis bon big little less mots comme je
suis comme j'étais un peu d'entrée de
jeu je trouve que c'est une des plus
belles choses qui a fait qu il y ait
comme spécial parce que c'est un film je
pense plus à vue qui est spécial pour
bien des gens parce que je pense à un
film qui nous ont accompagnés
collectivement ils commune quelque chose
de l'identité québécois entend parler un
peu peur mais il ya quelque chose dont
on se rappelle un peu quand c'est sorti
on leur visite de noël
quelque chose de rassembleur dans ce
sens le
ta cuisine et en plus dans la cas
spécial même pour moi dans la cause mais
ton l'artiste quittant maîtrise de son
langage pour moi c'est big le talent
c'est l'eau où on dirait comme jean marc
vallée il arrive dans la cour des grands
puis bien il est bien là le
sait les actrices et les actrices nicole
kidman les
hôtels déjà été meilleur parti pour moi
c'est il le dit lui même c'est est-ce
que c'était la télé des fonds utilise
surtout donner quand on est très chauvin
cinéma on utilise le terme à sa tête
télécom qui comme péjoratif c'est comme
puis
il n'y a rien dans big little est fait
et les au sens péjoratif du terme quand
un long film qui moi c'est souvent si
cyril hakim accroche le plus elysées
l'écouté en incitant dans un avion
j'avais un long vol i
say say say there à peu près dix l'ont
fait s'est passé comme ça c'est écrit
comme ceci guy a lepage ahmed à qui
demander gentil tu est appelé pour faire
des grandes séries à de lyon n'a jamais
fait et comment ça c'est qu'ils vont
chercher un débutant série télé je fais
rien changé ma manière surtout que ça
change pas vraiment sa manière de faire
parce qu'il ya quand même relativement
le nombre de jours où est le contrôle
artistique pis le sait il fait pas de là
il fait pas de la société image le petit
je pense pas qu'il faille pas des 10 15
20 pages par jour limiter vos films et
sur la latte sur un ps de cinéma facois
non moi je pense que ce que je voudrais
fait un long film c'est vraiment écrit
comme ça pour moi c'est les bois les
grandes séries télé c'est un peu ça
c'est sûr que parce que pour moi la fin
c'est il part importante et je
t'accompagne un spectateur vers
inexorable faut que tu le saches ont
inexorablement pour moi j'ai une
aversion pour les séries comme lost ou
l'impression qu'ils inventent des
commandes il se ramasse il se maintient
dans un coin pleut faut faire une finale
prix savait pas comment fini c'est pas
du tout sûr dans le code et séries et du
bio ça finit
là puis la grande mauvaise idée de
l'histoire des séries du bios et
puis si c'est impensable qui si je la
connaissais andrea arnold comme cinéaste
mais elle y incroyable de mes cinéastes
comme préféré qu'ils ont réalisé qu'ils
réalisent à 16h sauf que l as fait à peu
près dire y mettez y tu vas prendre une
amende et cinéaste iconoclaste qui
instille qu'une façon de faire puis tu
lui dis sans dire où tout au montage on
se rend compte mais on aimerait on
aimerait que ça et là de jean marc
vallée oies mais on en prenait puisque
rené si vous voulez une femme ou si
c'est possible mais je suis sûr qu'il y
en a mais lyon qui aurait comme fait la
job si les règles du jeu sont classés
comme on veut une série dans la logique
sites illicites et qu'esthétique de la
saison sûr qu'il y en aurait plus rien à
gagner à la pomme est pas prendre une
tignasse ultra chevronnés son langage à
elle pour apprécier l'idée rendre au
mont on aimerait ça finalement ça a
l'air surtout si comme tu as
développement de l'os et comme qu'est ce
que tu fais avec ce but et une saison
qui a un arc qui parfait qui aux tic qui
parfaitement écrit qui se terminait sur
la main d'or
l'oeuvre qui est là et est complétée de
la série qui mêle à la gauche
n'arrive loupe tout le monde continue et
ce système à 6 c'est beau c'est
impossible c'est impossible puis je
pense que je pense qu'après ce que
c'était que l'on spécule métier et
accueillis sont retrouvés le matériel et
qui est moins bon tactique après aussi
puis je pense que la cinéaste ensuite
c'est fait on peut couper les gens me
rende mon âge puis c'est fallait que ça
sonne familier hypothèse d'enquêté on a
remis du jean marc vallée in the hands
un peu partout dans la dent dans le
montage mais
il faut en parler
c'est pas le seul parce que non dit et
on se rappelle aussi dans ce moment là
cet épisode là il ya eu un peu jean marc
gallet était un peu comme un art il est
arrivé puis c'est comme un jerry dans le
travail d'andres arnold pire comme
certains c'est peut-être spécialisés le
bon moment de cinéma mais il ya beaucoup
de gens qui parlaient que c'est un peu
un deck move parce que comme il est
arrivé et puis d'ailleurs comme le doubs
dit sir pointé au montage il refile midi
alors que la vérité est beaucoup plus
complexe que ce mais non si le bref mais
comme une maison
à ce show qui était magnifique c'est une
des enfants béglé dollars je me rappelle
m'a dit j'ai rarement vu une ambiance
aussi bien établie genre ces mots si
c'est ce qui me fait capoter cj je
repense à cette série le g j'ai des
images claires qui me reviennent d'une
ambiance très vite et puis si on veut
revenait à ceux dont on en parle un peu
plus tôt ces jolies chansons se tient là
ses débuts et des totems ont pu écouter
le co2
la tombe de michael je dirais que
l'image du générique d'intro et sur
cette chanson là aussi pour moi c'est du
même niveau que tegra dormir when you be
well soon thibault misirlou de par sa
perfection nous
c'est vraiment une symbiose totale qui
fait que peu importe si t'es quoi la
vocation de la chanson tout ce qui était
tout ce qui est ce qui est arrivé à la
chanson avant avec les trahisons dray
était facile c'est ça deviendrait la
chanson originale john ça assez foule
c'est une sorte d'alchimie c'est ce long
terme en prendrait le messie c'est aller
total dix ans de l'album
c'est que drama
meloni mais le jean marc vallée ici il
peut il passe le plancher des vaches
tubes de ces femmes de banlieue de ce
village le n'écoute pas de musique le
lot des grands duels on s'en fiche son
temps on est dans ces l'auteur nous
prend par la main nous nous partage sa
playlist halimi depuis machu all in pour
ceux en laine pour se fiancer trop serré
du bio ne peut juste pas oui oui
quelques mains tantôt pis je parle à qui
parler je me disais imagine d'arriver
sur un plateau qui dirige l'actrice qui
a été dirigée par stanley kubrick
a travaillé avec genre le ce nom un des
plus grands réalisateurs de cinéma tout
arrive lui aussi comme ce que j'ai perçu
ça prend quand même intéressant qu'ils
légende confiance intéressant qui sait
ce mois manière quelconque pour le fun
on me l'avait demandé ça serait qu'ils
avaient kitsch restaure strates de
travailler qui moi c'est un briquet à ce
dont tu viens de parler témoin jeter
comme belle liv ullmann mettons c'est là
la grande actrice de bergman ne pas dire
manu plusieurs musées mais mettons-les
vraiment quand il est peut-être plus
grande performance petit comme mettons
le pied dans un monde bizarre le chiffre
est appelé à diriger l'événement
incapable peter fill a fait 35 films
avec bergman comme qu'est ce que je veux
dire
en ce sens c'est vrai que je pense des
gens comme ça au détriment des acteurs
comme sauter ou de juliette binoche tu
sais on travaille toutes les plus grands
cinéastes européens tilda swinton dans
ce moment à travailler a dit à des
collections comme des pokémon 10,9
incroyable le cas chez morneau mais
également le ou catherine deneuve les
autobus et ses tarifs toile mais mais
souvent les bons acteurs qui dure dans
la durée qui sont là dans la durée
volandri il aime se diriger ils vont ici
ont embarqué ont embarqué était à
tabarka pour après surfer tête pour
apprécier aux échos que moi j comme sont
exactement dans quelques semaines est
dithyrambique par rapport à jean marc
vallée le puits à commande qu'ils
allaient aimer travailler avec lui c'est
comme si ces mouvements qui elle aussi
s'était de nouveau dans sa carrière
ok même celles investies carrière c'est
quand même un rôle qui était le c'était
quand même un petit bout de temps que
chez pol on en voyait moins un mois ou
qui n'avaient pas montré qu'elles
avaient pas filer comme
tu parlais des cinq kiki film n est
aucunement que les scènes d'action marié
d'espèces de violence qui se transforme
en sexualité puis en parler jean marc
vallée sur le plateau tout le monde en
parle mais sur le plateau pendant que ça
se tourne cette affaire le ça doit pas
être la chose la plus dure à nantes au
monde entier sur la tête tu es un même
dessein de même
oui parce que tu veux
ça creuse iris pauvreté ça creuse dans
des vraies émotions quand même c'est oui
on le dit on fait un script mais un
scénario mais où aller
mais je pense que tu sais ce lait reese
witherspoon les nicole kidman quand ils
écrivent sion chaud le entre les mains
le scénario lente les mains ils vont
chercher un cinéaste qui savent qui
pourra les entendre on peut les pousser
c'est parce que ça leur tente whissell
et jacques pessis et des beaux des
filles
d'acteurs tifa que je veux dire tu sais
que tu dois faire tu fais pas qu'un
steak qui te fais pas exprès ti de
commandes sache que tu fais en rien le
faire pourquoi le faire refaire à
outrance pin perdre la confiance de
l'acteur bâti analogie sportive c'est
mettons que je te demande de faire 1 100
mah est à vitesse maximale des pressions
de lipitor finalement jeune orphelin une
honte il va tous être plus
exact
mais il faut que ces
mêmes l analogique perdu au stade quand
une demande réellement une performance à
100% le mot performance est bien choisie
en fait c'est un athlète de l'émotion
d'une certaine façon et et en étant
performant cela que tire faut absolument
que tu leur permettent de briller pitts
uni fait unis brûlent pas outrance non
plus tu essaies si visuellement c'est
bref mettez pour moi c'est ça revient au
respect ça revient c'est peut-être qu'à
hollywood où beaucoup ou aux états il ya
peut-être beaucoup de cinéastes
comme quand tu arrives avec une attitude
de collaboration qui est très positive
je pense comme je le disais tantôt je
pense que tu es déjà dans le bon moment
dans l'aude paris nombreux
sont derrière eux ouais sharp objets que
je suis un peu plus partager l'eau où il
réussit énormément c était dans la
paranoïa de banlieue ces genres c'est
pour moi c'est une hyper bonne
utilisation des racques foyer qu'on
appelle le terrain quand le foyer par
exemple sur la personne en avant qu'il
passe à la personne en arrière c'est
dans chapeau abject que tout le temps la
personne qui regarde ou qu'ils écoutent
très improbable ron puis c'est qui c'est
quoi le ceci est quelque chose de très
peu de voyeurisme des petits villages
exactement mais qu' il ya une grande
grande maîtrise de son langage je trouve
pour pont pour nous faire vivre c'est
très exigeant
journaliste l'eau qui arrive de la ville
qui revient dans son petit village pour
couvrir des moeurs dit un mur qui arrive
jours qu'elle arrive quasiment bon bref
on la sent cette angoisse l'appui moi ce
que j'ai aimé c'est le petit renne
méthodique à cette espèce denquête le
sait peut-être son cette grande qualité
puis son plus grand défaut en ce sens
que ça avance à un rythme qui règne mais
ce faisant on dirait que parfois çà çà
çà çà tourne peut-être un petit peu en
rond je me sens bien je pense c'est en
fait c'est que c'est quand même plus
long québec les taux largement semble
content seulement après les épisodes
sont plus longs je pense que c'est une
bonne heure le de plus qui je passe à
paris c'est qu'on le masi peut-être que
cette horloge est trop et peut-être un
ou deux épisodes de trop bon bref
amy adams et il faut qu'on croit qu'il
est là mais on n'y croit pas tant parce
qu amy adams est trop amy adams au
risque de faire un commentaire qui sont
en permanence métis comme je dois à se
retirer comme ses cheveux comme
parfaitement ondulée hypothécaires c'est
ça c'est le clash est là il faut que je
crois que c'est keita de brefs donc il
ya faire comme sa droite à gauche hip
hop cru totalement la finale et tout bon
bref mai mais reste qu'une maîtrise du
langage je pense que c'est ce qui
ressort ce qui ressort c'est cela tu
voudrais qu'il a fait comme lemieux ont
montré qu'un matériel qu'avez vous
ressenti ça parce que c'est ça aussi la
pense que les les la difficulté travail
et du matériel qui parce que tu écrivais
expulsés comme acquis il faut que je
rende ce faut que je rende le meilleur
2e sauf que j'ai l'impression qu'à la
base le matériel était de quoi dans le
scénario il ya de quoi dans cette
histoire lucky qui passe et engageant
tous qui manque qui est de marque un fil
conducteur loi mais
en
même temps ce que j'ai aimé c'est une
série qui travaille beaucoup les les
clichés hommes femmes dans les films des
trucs dans le car était déjà émis adapté
on dit que j'avais des images de film
noir le titre l'enquêteur qui alcolock
ce point qui fait son tic mais là c'est
déjà des jeux de féminiser le
protagonisme mêmes bon genre et on n'en
révèlera pas trop mais même ensuite dans
qu'est ce qui découle
au niveau 2 des hommes des femmes
devant quelque chose d'intéressant je
trouve dans des genres âge puisqu'il pas
non plus tendancieuses sais pas comment
j'ai des gens râlent genre quitus
encaissés ouais c'est ça qui est ça le
cocher la case sacoche toutes les bonnes
causes le pour être dans l'air du temps
non moi j'ai bien aimé quelque chose sur
le côté mais te dit que la chose d'un
peu classique hollywood dans cette
espèce de tant qu'athlète j'ai bien
aimer vraiment
mais même avec ça ça nous fait donc sa
livrée pour tous ces projets qu'ils ne
seront pas bons c'est qu'il y avait un
projet avec john et yoko
entre autres bons la pilule biopic
commises avec amy adams ou janis joplin
je vais encore une fois dans un univers
parallèle où cette oeuvre le existe
c'est que mes chances à ces deux projets
c'est parce que si on parle de la
musique dans ses oeuvres dans toutes ces
oeuvres tpiy c'est clairement un
mélomane qui intègre la musique dans ses
films de madame présentes mais qui ai
pas fait un film sur la musique soit
c'est vrai ces mélodies avec succès du
projet leur puis je pense le projet une
adéquation parfaite on dirait le
prochain c'était vraiment celui sur sur
john pillot copie justement dans le même
paquet ce que j'écoutais ya parlé
beaucoup le t2 de hung interrompu un
processus puis
les recherches qui avaient fait petits
deals rendu dit je dois être dans le top
10 des experts dans le monde sur la
relation john et
musicologue c'est vraiment une storia
cette période de 66 à 80 j'ai tout vu
les entrevues j'ai tout lu les livres là
dessus j'ai tout est acquis teramo rendu
près andré à l'attaqué
dommage qu'on contraire parce qu'il y
avait toutes sélectionnées les toons
charnière dans lequel john où il y au
côté
parlé de la relation de la mode ce qui
s'est arrêté comme le tremplin le tram
le fil conducteur on verra jamais se
fait menacer rend un hommage appuyé pour
backtrack pourrait faire un petit
flashback notamment parce que c'est pas
leader les films de genre marques l'ont
bien de conversation ne doit pas trop
l'être métier moi j'ai donc appris son
décès je pense qu'elle est ce le matin
le soir du 26 décembre que ça a été
publique moi je te les connecter ce soir
le même lendemain matin ils m'ont
évidemment c'est
cela oui évidemment évidemment j'aime
amon ago mabulle son algorithme est très
cinéma donc même pour les gens qui ont
un hangar est passionnément menons
actuellement avec absolument puis moi
tout de suite avant même que bon boulot
maintenant il ya beaucoup de monde qui
ont fait du millage intellectuelle sur
cette île le mais moi je te connais
aussi noël qui noël je vais tout de
suite la ligne de crédit qui met nos
lanternes c'est vraiment vraiment puis
l'on se parle on est en début d'année on
sort de noël c'est quand même encore moi
c'est encore un peu surréaliste non
autorisée on en a parlé abondamment il
délivre les loges se multiplient l'on
voit si on vient de parler pendant x
nombre de temps de son oeuvre donc quand
ça pullule ça se multiplient mais on
dirait qu'il ya encore quelque chose
dans la pub choisi jean et entraîne au
rythme record le oui non mais sont ils
contents ils croient comme pas trop le
montrer qu'on sort d'un mauvais rêve
c'est très curieux puis
c'est sûr j'ai comme instantanément eu
la réplique de crise' le dos là je me
rappelle j'ai toujours détesté noël
c'est audrey mon dieu c'est les lilas
tragique ironie
et les
faits c'est une tristesse mais c'est
vraiment
il pas bon pour les médecins si confort
il ya dans l'absurdité de cette
tristesse le sait que les réserves d'or
c'est que l'immortalité
par une certaine façon comme ce site est
réellement la mort de l'auteur mettez
crazy cuisi je pense à vous ça va
toujours rester un des films marquants
du cinéma québécois
forever seulement phi phi phi phi de
l'airé de son oeuvre aussi avec du bio
avec big night lights moi je pense qu'il
est un peu aussi un avant et un après
dans une taie d'oreiller vraiment il est
vrai avant de laisser sa marque sans
faire de mauvais jeu de mots puis mais
c'est ça c'est ce ticket le vers
l'immortalité
permettre la métaphysique cesser ses
oeuvres d'art valable vrai qui résonne
qui parle qui émeuvent qui inspire ça ça
ça va ça risque c'est quoi la chose
principale que tu veux que tu gardes
avec toi
de jean marc vallée dans d'un pour la
suite des choses pour ton travail de
réalisateur pourtant moi c'est une
ambition mais une ambition qui se
travestit jamais qui est toujours
personnelle comme disait moi je trouve
ça beau qu'il s'en soit quelqu'un qui
ait réussi à donc ça tirait
sur tous ces éloges leleu peu importe
mon époque on court après ce même et en
restant quand même assez lui même
puisque au musée c'est peut-être cette
espèce de début de carrière en semi faut
des ports le dont on parle pas trop ces
espèces de tête ses films américains et
le un peu anonyme un peu georges fais ce
qu'on me demande si j'essaie d'avoir
l'air d'un singe savant puis qu'ensuite
non écoute le peut-être que je me suis
un petit peu égarée en faisant cela et
ensuite il y avait plus des garanties 10
il y en a eu un geste ne peut considérer
peut-être on parlait de mon talent le
queen victoria au point fort de young
victoria mais mais mais moi c'est
d'avoir réussi à être autant
fidèle à ses manières à son style dans
plein de sujets différents puis d'avoir
réussi effectivement émouvoir
quand tu patines peut-être un peu mais
n'ont cessé de détruire à est un artiste
singulier dans une machine un peu ça
c'est mon jugement hors europe ce projet
parce que c'est un québécois je dirai ce
jeu serait pas de casque peut-être
déniché sur le cinéma qu'on parlerait
d'un cinéaste comme lui mais c'était
hongrois
j'aurai la même chose
il ya je l'entendais raconter une
histoire qui explique inquiéter jeune a
12 n'était pas très clairement signifié
le tpiy qui s'est vraiment rendu au
cégep a fait qu' il était comment
programme générique l'audience humaines
puis le bris en cours des cinémas en
option se disant ça va être facile puis
la 6éme au cégep s'arrêtera là depuis
que système le prof de secours le bilan
à 32 coureurs puis qui dit que les cours
de 3h paraissait comme 15 minutes puis
quelle heure je me suis rendu compte que
c'était cette forme d'art le
relativement tard des fautes 6 votes
disney vont dire j'ai toujours su que
les fans cinéma ou du tpiy et basses que
j'ai l'impression qu'il y mettons là la
marque dire que cela a eu sur lui et lui
de lavaur sur
baltique qui ont écouté crise et aux
côtés des clés de la conquête
jamais tes données irradié un hameau
comme seul parce que je trouve qu'il ya
trop de médias mainstream qui incite les
gens ne pas être curieux soit je trouve
que c'est d'une énorme c'est un site est
tragique c'est quand tu fais quand quand
tu fais des articles sur le genre un tel
film mais à l'upr reçu trop douce et
rossi ou s'est passé ce aussi c'est moi
j'ai quand même des genres et invitons
dont la curiosité hippie dont la piqûre
c'est ce qui est beau c'est ce que lui
faisait beaucoup moi à mon échelle de
cinq ans qu'on me demande des fois
d'aller parler dans les écoles de voir
des étudiants je les fais tout le temps
parce que je sais à quel point c'est
important pour moi c'est ce qui a fait
en sorte que moi aussi j'avais pas
nécessairement une cinéaste à 15 16 ans
mais ses rangs du cégep universités
quand j'ai eu ces rencontres le sait
électrochoc le selor que ça m'a vraiment
conforté pu me dire akhenaton gimeaux le
cj va aller là dedans bref si ces
données cette piqûre le ça vaut quelque
chose qui était vraiment un instrumental
dans
parmi les cinéastes québécois le qui
sait ce qu'ils faisaient ce donc
[Musique]
c'est triste mais pour
avant de terminer le podcast chef
styliste
devant deux autres l'ont été en début
d'année c'est quoi ton top 5 des films
de 2021 parce que je sais que je te
demande le top 5 pour les gens qui nous
écoutent le désormais intimement le top
5 ce mini-site une mine de spath et
pascal ya des listes pour littéralement
des barres car je sais qu'on se
comprenne que naît son top 5 des cinq
quatre trois deux un parc éolien
on mettra ça
c'est honteux je peux sur instagram et
sur leur box j'éteins voici autres
monnaies mais baccout cinq films cinq
films non mais je pourrais peut-être que
je veux ce qui permet mais vraiment plus
d'obstruction genre pas disponibles
veulent pas parce que j'ai vu au
festival
s'est
vu à cannes
ça se plaint mais je vois je conseille
un pikmin string moi c'est mon fils mon
groupe battre mon pikmin string de
streaming américain mettons j'ai adoré
ping de maïs en hausse ticket avec une
casquette je sais qu'il est vraiment
superbe
c'est comme si nicholas kelly john drake
il ya péter décoche dans les dix
dernières années au cinéma puis l'oeil
comme quelqu'un qui s'est dit non on
veut prendre colas kate moore faire
quelque chose dit
non mais que sait on espère que c'est
mon moment mon penchant et mainstream
sur les plateformes de streaming mom en
string cinéma ces deux-là ce duo de
glace que papy ridley 81,3 un scénario
flegme à damon est ce que c'est vrai
qu'il n'est pas un gladiator 2 j'en ai
même pas d'autre part une fois que ce
soit d'autre non mais j'ai pas quels
sont tes sources non nommées d'alarmé
mettant mon top
mon top 4 s'ils n'ont pas encore
américain red rocket john baker jean
becker pour ceux qui saurait il ya fait
des fêtes un film s'appelle tandja ring
est magnifique mais il ya fait aussi de
fleurs de project qui tu es l'immense
des années son nouveau film c'est sur un
point duster qui revient il y revient il
faut qu'il y arrive de elie retour dans
son patelin
il veut surfer tir mais comme suit un
personnage un peu comme si vous avez mis
en cause james était ce genre de
personnage 3 carine qui butine de
mauvaises décisions en mauvaise décision
pis que tu sais pas politically correct
le sait vraiment rome le comm
réd c'est une ch'ti de deux montagnes
russes numéro 3 je mettrais and it de
leos carax les opérations
je sais qu'on a on adore ou on déteste
j'adore
ce
c'était le fait l'ouverture de cannes
cette année puis je pense que c'est un
statement parce que c'est un électrochoc
sommes un éloge au cinéma tandis que le
cinéma parle il ya de la musique tedx a
pu parler ça pue santé du cinéma bis on
dit que dans son sort de la pâte ballon
sort plus la pandémie mais aussi un
micro mais mettons à l'été l'animation
penser qu'on s'en sorte et puis je pense
que c'était le parfait message en le
cinéma ville vive le cinéma
tus les tous les codes les comédies
musicales mais en les testant par les
renards oui je sais comment se prennent
et mettait cette année aussi ouais ce
week-end
dans un filtre genre elle est filtrée
et nommé annette métier qu'on aime qu'on
déteste si on aime le cinéma y est à
bord c'est vraiment une claque qui met
le premier c'est le même cinéaste sert
péniche et mais s'il s'appelle ryusuke
hamaguchi
donc déjà fait de longs métrages un qui
été primé à berlin qui a été primée
encore une fois quand c'est quand il le
prix du scénario mon fils s'appelle
sur un metteur en scène de théâtre qui a
perdu sa femme puis l'on souhaite il
peut pas conduire à cause de sa voiture
à cause des assurances il le chauffeur
peut importe quel synappci je vais en
faire ça sera vraiment vraiment vraiment
moins bon que le film ce genre de film
qui a énormément d'humanité qui parlent
à notre homme qui parle à son lui
maillon nous piquer tellement juste
brillant intelligent bien fait tête ça
c'est vraiment accord qui ait fait un
ultime qui s'appelle wheel of fortune en
fantasy qui est un film très que l'uss
dans le fond ce que j'ai fait et deux
top firme 2003 et après c'était donc le
crime est un et il le fait où la fortune
j'aurais peut être pu le mettre pas 12e
mais comme et quand je suis comme non
c'est le cinéaste est pour moi c'est un
peu comme quand j'ai rencontré âge d'or
farhadi début 2010 quand j'avais vu à sa
parution de chiffres de mai justin à ses
clients ses films d'après d'avant j'ai
fait des annonces donner du mon cinéaste
au monde pour moi ryoichi kawaguchi ça
est une de mes rencontres cinéma le
marquand tsébo hardrige on est comme lui
en crise les films c'est beau quand je
te manges découvre un auteur classique
en main gauche à l'époque et yahi
exister ce japonais le qui parle à mon
humble directement
c'est pour moi c'est le de l'année puis
la dernière fois qu'on s'est parlé quand
est venu pour parler de nadia briefly tu
avais un projet sur le grill mettons
projet a changé les réglages je
travaille sur cosmo oui c'est ça c'est
ben oui puis non plus en plus c'est très
concret parce qu'on une belle nouvelle
en fin d'année 2021 avant le 17 juin on
est une belle nouvelle c'est que en fait
on le feu vert de la sodec donc pour la
production de mon prochain long métrage
de fiction ça s'appelle les chambres
rouge
oui c'est sur une balle courbe parce que
j'ai passé 2020 a scénarisé a
coscénarisé un film sur les filles droit
film d'époque j'en avais même parlé à ce
micro aussi un petit peu le et puis
finalement les allées aux du financement
puis deux c'est un film qui peut poste
on y cohabitent des jeux des films de
genre ançardine dans un bas trou avec la
maladie tout donc impossible avec les
mesures en place mais c'est pas la vraie
raison la vraie raison c'est que c'était
trop ambitieux c'est un film qu'on peut
pas faire à moitié s'est taillé comme
une genres de l'imaginaire en dessous de
laquelle m'ont aidé à m'en parle
d'argent mais en dessous de laquelle on
peut juste pas le faire à la hauteur nos
ambitions déjà des films sur les filles
du roi il y en a comme pas vraiment eu
fait qu'il faut que ce soit bien fait
puis on veut pas ou ne peut pas le faire
artisanal ou comme pour cambiale il
est en gestation longtemps mais qui va
sauter puis on a travaillé très fort le
scénario en faire un coproduction
peut-être avec l'europe à voir des
acteurs et de france et du québec mon
bref ça s'enligne pour être un gros
projet mais il sur la glace active parce
que c'était de la production continue à
faire ce qu'elle a à faire pour que ça
se passe mais on en sait des gardes tu
sais quoi on va faire un film qui peut
se faire dans le contexte québécois
relativement rapidement et fort
heureusement j'avais une autre idée
fille qui est venue d'une amie à ma
copine qui a été juré au procès magne
auteur très glauque mais qui voyait tous
les jours les deux mêmes filles qui
venaient assister au procès pics qui ont
comme suit ben non ce sont des fans en
fait ce sont des femmes qui sont obsédés
par magnéto qui sont amoureuses ou bon
et puis le donc le phénomène des
groupies de thouars le moment comme
vraiment fasciné j'ai fait beaucoup de
recherches là dessus c'est un phénomène
qui datent pas d'hier mais qui est
exacerbé par les médias sociaux bien
évidemment et je n'ai pas eu quelques
sueurs va voir ces femmes pdc même pot
un même pot en drogue dès le soir le
quitus sont dix sept personnes sur l'île
en norvège y'a comme descente et des
dizaines et des dizaines de pages sur
facebook les gens qui l'aiment ou autres
le tice et s'écoulent charles manson
recevais mes lettres par annie
appréciable notamment de barrage à tous
les jours que ces séquences et capoter
la réflexion je veux pas épiloguer mais
la réflexion c'est que plus le toit est
médiatisé ce une courbe directement
proportionnel sata plus le soir est
traitée au rockstore plus il ya des
femmes s'est littéralement ce pourquoi
les femmes seules en série ont peut-être
pas autant d'admirateurs c'est parce que
le traitement médiatique et il ya deux
morts les femmes trustent déjà y en a
moins mais lorsqu'elles sont le ce sont
les cartes ra trice par excellence les
montres religieux tu t'approches pas de
tuer un bâton mais si tu as un petit
côté vampire séduisant et jamais bien
loin le petit con mais plus de séries
sur ted bundy puisse ôter ses histoires
leleu qui avait un certain charme
la seconde d'arc est un jean et des
fameux pervers narcissique puisqu'à part
et est donc moi je réfléchis nommément
au rôle des médiaux piste a
essentiellement bref c'est un suspense
judiciaire parce que c'est un coach
c'est un film qui se passe pendant le
procès d'un tueur fictifs qui opère
crédit des red room sur le dark web donc
des vidéos de ce 9 mai live avec des
gens qui tu es plus en plus tôt et enfin
que encore une fois c'est la recherche
très glauque qui m'a amené à tous ceux
et mais là il s'est fait soigner loyers
jugés pionce je suis finalement ce
procès-là et les dénouement du procès
mais du point de vue d'une femme qui est
obsédée par lui
grosso modo les chances
comment ça va faire une parenthèse sur
le sujet on commence à voir un switch
pareil en de la mana contre
parce que c'est sûr que quelqu'un qui
aimait tant
obsédé par
recherché doit être devenir une espèce
de d'icônes septimaniaque
l'allemagne auteuil tel paroxysme jeudi
c'était si on a le risque analysé lui
cette espèce de quête maladive leur
d'attention puis de devenir célèbre et
puis bon il réussit d'une certaine façon
les aspects de mon ami john lynch panama
c'est peut être que c était la victime
de magnéto mais alors que lui je laisse
la vedette planétaire vedette dans
drôles de mômes et quand même si c'est
comme ça des médias l'ont traité
de amy compagnie s'est jamais été aussi
belle c'est définitivement une
fascination pour ce monde bah oui pcb et
donc moi je rends un peu le spectateur
complice de cette fascination là parce
que tu es si nous en tant que
spectateurs du film que j'aimerais faire
que je veux faire on est un peu
injustement oubliée par le soir en
question tout à coup on rentre dans la
tête du personnage qu'ils étaient
manipulés par lui tpiy puis justement le
lieu pour moi ce qui conforte mon idée
c'est effectivement s'il que la
popularité du toucan mais jamais été
aussi élevé et puis à quel point comme
je te dis
c'est des vaches à lait les ted bundy
les lakers
jerry dammers
charles manson quand il pourrait sortir
en affaires net repli qui doit même que
ce serait des millions de gens qui le
regarde je fais
et donc moi je trouvais ça pipi mois en
fait toutes les idées mes films je peux
peut-être
cette façon mais ça me vient tout le
temps de comme je le dis j'écoute
beaucoup de films donc regardé beaucoup
de films un magnéto qu'un bailleur ce
qui se fait énormément puis c'est ce
genre de film le étrange que tu vois
dans ta taille mais que tu vois pas
vraiment diction parfaite finalement ce
pour moi c'est la plus belle porte
d'entrée de création parce que je me dis
bien si j'aimerais voir un film qui
n'existe pas encore ou un point de vue
ou une traitement esthétique ou peu
importe si ça n'a pas été vraiment fait
alors gauthier c'est moi ou aixam
légitimise au lieu de suivre une
tendance qu'il arrivait à la traîne pas
c'est l'enfer un film si tu veux faire
un érudit terry aujourd'hui confirme ça
en 2023 et l'état de paris en tant que
faux faux faux pour moi je pense pour
pas penser comme ça faut plus penser à
ce que ce que le désir de battre price
était que la natation s'est représenté
comme la marde les athlètes ont jamais
de l'art d'athlètes la psychologie de la
tête puis le triomphe dans les films est
un mensonge il faut parler d'erreur du
revers de tout ce finalement c'est
l'inspiration vient de ce que je vois
pas
pipi
scientifique fou parce qu'il prend un
parti-pris complément aux autres qui
renverse plusieurs coeurs depuis très
courts et aux é
u départ à la ferme ton cinéma puisse
émettre mardi qu'en compensation
de la musique vraiment représente piqué
ce soit aussi présent dans la dans la
vie des personnages faisant des films
puis
des personnages féminins forts c'est
dans tout près ce que tu t'es fait
monter court métrage les personnages
féminins les formes et y mettons quand
on regarde la filmographie de lamballe
et la majorité des films
surtout vers la fin me till the world
jusqu'à jusqu'à chanter objets beaucoup
de personnages féminins
mots coulent le lot où j'ai vraiment pas
le même cerveau
pour mieux aux populations est
complètement différent c'est que lui il
fragmente ces récits d'une façon super
intéressante alors que moi j'aime
beaucoup plus moi je les colle un peu
mais j'adore john cassavetes bonhomme
est plein de cinéaste si vous regardez
les films damas gucci vous allez voir le
sedif justement des longues semaines
mais qui prennent le temps puis c'est
vraiment oublie le tendre et oublie
cinéma moi j'aime ça puis jean margalit
fait jamais oublier cinéma parce que son
montage côté très très expressif moi
j'aime bien c'était cette idée d pinos
par l'image qui les lie moment que ces
tirs et entend coin je dirais la plus
grande différence réelle hommes et wiba
ou qu'il écoute on va le prendre
des parts ou itunes compagnie on n'avait
rien à l'éducation oui moi je voulais
repérages en tout début de film
un
troisième round le deuxième maillot ziem
par exemple
peut-être y
est ça et merci beaucoup bastien
du contenu excellente à tout un podcast
combien
oui
si vous voulez plus de contenu excellent
comme ce que vous venez d'entendre aller
sur une pétillante répétions vous
abonner pour trop dollars par mois c'est
trop de longs mois et trois pièces par
morlaàs par mois et vous avez les pas de
carte en avance acquise avec les
premiers de votre groupe d'amis avoir
quitté les podcasts qu'ils allaient
avoir pouvoir avoir une avance quand
vous à l'étude de la dynamique entre les
amys tout le temps avons une avance sur
les jobs en avance ou des centres de toi
mais avec pétillante une avance sur
l'humanité complète en plus en plus
parce que le ch et que le podcast unis
voulaient nous en jazz ou davantage on
fait des encore moins de filtres à
préchac podcast avec là on vient de
finir de tourner le podcast on vend
jaser on va t'il et nicole non nicolas
hulot maintenant comme un fils travaille
à plat ce détail est là mais on jason
par la conversion qu'on m'aide à voir
mais ce si vous voulez avoir accès
mais heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous c'est exclusif
sur pékin il faut s'abonner abonnez vous